this is the main show this is the danger
bismillah al hamd allah salam alaikum
greetings of peace peace be to you thank
you for tuning in to the Dean show now
I'm very excited here that you've come
to us you've come to learn and you've
gotten away from everything else from
the hustle and bustle of life you
decided to really take the matter
seriously purpose of life why are you
here where you're going when you die you
came from somewhere and where you're
going when you leave this world it's a
very important issue but now you've
heard some names you want to call upon
the one who created you who gave you
life will give you def the One God some
people say that look yahweh is god
that's the proper name for the Creator
some people go ahead and and make this
mighty messenger whose beloved to our
hearts jesus peace be upon him no muslim
is a muslim unless he believes in jesus
some people call God is Jesus or give
Jesus to equal status to God and then
some people over 1.5 billion call God by
the name of Allah which means the only
one worthy of worship so how does all
this fit in place Yahweh Jesus Allah
this is what we're going to be talking
about on this week's show don't go
nowhere we'll be right back this is the
team the d
this is the thing this is the things is
the danger
this is the video this is the days of
Athene jus this is the things i'm here
with the president of the Islamic
research education foundation president
Imran how are you Tom DeLonge find peace
be with you bisbee the 22 very important
topic that we're here to cover you have
your own private section at the Dean
show calm hummed in law praise to the
credit that the Dean show is glued is
viewed all over the globe on many
satellite channels but for those that
don't get to watch it on the TV you can
watch it at the Dean show calm and you
have your own section there people can
click on your section and watch the
other programs that we've done today
we're going to be talking about God's
proper name some people say Jehovah the
word Jehovah or Yahweh some people they
make Jesus into god we love Jesus but we
know that he never claimed to be God so
they give him the rights of God and then
we have a la so to clear up the
confusion where do we start yeah in
other words looks like Yahweh Jesus
Christ and Allah other the same so the
answer would be no they are not the same
yes but one thing is very clear the God
who created the Muslims it is the same
God who created the Jews and the
Christians a Jew will also agree that
God who created the Jew is the same God
who created the entire universe a
Christian to agree that the God who
created it Chris him is the same God who
created the entire universe and we
Muslims to have no objection to believe
that the God who created the Muslims it
is the same God who created the entire
universe but what a Muslim is very
strong in his belief is about belief
in a las 10 dolla the word Allah many
people think is a word that was coined
by prophet muhammad sallallahu salam
this is a misinformation this is a wrong
knowledge because you see the prophet
prophet muhammad the peace be upon him
he claimed his messenger hood his
prophethood when he was 40 years old he
was 40 years old when he said that
Archangel Gabriel came to me with a
revelation from Allah Subhanahu tala but
his father's name was Abdullah this
would mean that the word Allah was
commonly if you read the Encyclopedia
Britannica it says that Allah was the
standard name of God in Arabic for the
Arab since a long time and of course
according to one of the great historians
mr. Marshall in one of his books he says
that there were certain Christian groups
who went to Makkah before the birth of
prophet muhammad aslam they went to
Makkah to circumambulate the Kaaba
calling it by Tula meaning the house of
allah meaning for the Coptic Christians
and Jews for those Christians and Jews
who were born Jews and Christians in the
Arab land speaking Arabic as the mother
tongue these Christians and Jews refer
to the Almighty God as Allah very
conveniently but now when you see Yahweh
Jesus Christ for me did these terms come
who is Yahweh if you read the Holy
Scripture of the Jews that is the taurah
the Pentateuch in the Pentateuch one
very commonly repeated name which they
refer to the God is Yahweh which occurs
more than 6,700 x 6000 time 6700 time
where's issues it's used in the Old
Testament all possible yea to and you
how do you say they call it Y hat
wh-which is water Lee no cha wh I would
definitely like to throw some light on
how did yhew
become Yahweh so they say that in the
book of Exodus you will find in Chapter
number 30 verse number 32 was over for
din jab number 32 was about 32 verse /
14 you will find that Moses may peace be
upon him when he asked the Almighty God
who are you what's your name and that if
I came to him I am that I am i am that i
am say to the people of Israel that I am
sent me so who is this I am so the heavy
you closes to it they say is the root
heads white hatch hi it's from this
route hi that yhw H came and the common
do it modern Jew or any Jew of the time
would not like anyone to take the name
of the God because they say it is too
sacred it is in Fe able it should not be
wised it's very sacred it is a great sin
to take his name outside so they don't
want to take his name outside in the
Bible when it appeared for more than six
thousand seven hundred times in the Old
Testament what they did is they
substituted that word with a Greek world
Adonai Adonai is a Greek word which
translated into English it means my lord
but still what is yuck wait what is
Yahweh so they say Yahweh is I am what I
am so if you say I am that IM is Yahweh
then it is not a noun it is a causative
verb it's not a noun we are talking of
for now i am that i am is not a noun it
is a causative verb hi hyh hi hi is the
route to Yahweh and high means to be one
who originates the beam I am that I am
hi is very close to the Arabic cognate
an attribute of Allah in surah Baqarah
surah number two at number 200
25 which we refer as ayatul kursi which
is allah allah allah allahu allah allahu
allahu allahu allah allahu allah besides
him there is no other God who won high
you'll high um-- he is hi hi means the
everliving everliving the one who is
forever the ever living is high from
that so if hi-yah hee Eun these are the
attributes of the Almighty God a las 10
dolla so there could be an attribute of
God yes it can be an attribute of God
but who is this why HW hedge and how did
why HW hedge which the refer as
tetragram a shin how did it become
yahuwah so we come to know that a person
is scholar by the name jesse Gnaeus in
the 9th century christian era he added
war else to these consonants yhew heads
are consonants he added war else to
these consonants from taking out the
walls of the word adenine ad Oh nai if
you check a zone I eh oh eh are the
three vials in that word so he took out
these three wines a 0 and a and put it
between yhw H between y & H he put the a
of other nine that biggest with a a it
becomes yeah then do that oh he put out
put between H & W it became yahoo and
the last of Adonai after a comes I in
other night that he took and put after w
it became yahuwah that is how yahoo
hobby came into existence and when you
check the common term in have you use
for the god is Elohim L is a heavy wood
in Syriac it is a la lah inward in
Syriac language it is a la lah very
close to Allah of Arabic if you check
the heavier language the shot is ly em
so they say Elohim for respect it is a
plural of respect but the same Elohim we
do not believe that Elohim is Allah
because if you read the Bible the word
Elohim has been used for the dead
spirits it has been used to refer
two celestial objects with six wings it
has been used to refer to the demons
it's so confusing you cannot get to the
base what exactly Yahweh or Elohim is
there's so much to add on this I got so
many more questions we're going to take
a break and we'll be right back with
more with the president of the iref here
on the Dean she'll be right back what is
close to death that's all God don't let
me die but he's got something better
than this world what's God going to get
out of punishing you anyway you have to
connect to this understanding that the
court n is from God that Muhammad is His
Messenger and the answers to the
problems in our life are there and if
we're going to worship something I
figured I might as well worship the
Creator instead of any of the creations
back here on the D show and Yahweh Jesus
a law is it's all the same and we're
clearing this up you're explaining it so
simple but it just we got to mix a
little confusing to the average person
never heard this is like whoa my head's
a little spin him and you know a law is
the only god to be worshipped simple
done but now that's amazing we have the
verbatim got word of God it clears up
all the confusion all the chaos is out
there because here you don't have the
original books and you're relying on
translations and you come up with you
mention some guys named he change that
this prayer changes what you're doing
changing if it's from God you can't
change it once it changes now from God
better so let's continue on clearing up
the confusion to make it a little
absolutely so that's what that's what
I'm saying that if you want to worship
the God you should at least know
something very clear about God and not
confusing and if you do a little bit of
more study into Judaism and how the
Torah was compiled how was it brought
back because the Torah given to musa
alehsalaam was destroyed in the first
attack on the temple of solomon mud
before that it was destroyed but it got
totally destroyed on in the first attack
by nebuchadnezzar when he attacked in
586 BC he destroyed the entire
so what is there in the Torah today has
been compiled on a theory known as
documentation hypothesis documentation
hypothesis and this is known in short
form as d h it has got four main sources
to get but the subject compiled into
this book one of them is the source of
jehovahs or the yahoo waste and if the
other sources ello hist now when you
check what a jehovahs defines Yahweh as
he will be surprised they define Yahweh
as a God walking in the garden of eden
as a god who is designing clothes for
adam and eve as a god who is visiting
the people and speaking to them
face-to-face this is Jehovah Witnesses
no not the Jehovah Witnesses that
Jehovah's source the Jehovah's source of
the Jews yeah who brought this world
violation of the Torah OIC which is ever
said in the documentation hypothesis
there are four main sources okay two of
them are Jehovah's and yellow hist so
the Jehovah's concept is he is a God in
form walking in the Eden searching where
are you Adam this is in Genesis now now
this is the book of Genesis but what I'm
trying to actually give you is they're
trying to picture eyes the God as a
person like a human workings of a
talking to the people this is wrong this
rom and ello hist have a different
picture all together meaning the two
main groups who are the main sources for
the documentation hypothesis to compile
the Torah they have difference of
opinion about the one God the Almighty
God Allah Subhanahu Tala but you see as
I said this Yahoo a concept became so
unpopular and was so confusing that they
said it's two separate let's not take
the name let's call him I don't I oh now
we got another thing and I'm glad you
said confusing cuz I thought I'm losing
it now many people risk a few yeah
absolutely it's so confusing that nobody
can solve this mystery yeah it's
mysterious what did you go on from here
you said they why don't I now what's
this that's a Greek term which has been
substituted wherever the word Yahweh
came and if you check
today this word Adonai has been used to
replace Yahweh because it is a very
sacred name and I don't I is a Greek
term meaning my lord as we say in rugby
Allah is rubble the Cherisher the Lord
rugby my lord it's an attribute so in
the King James Version what is what's
its they all I don't I is a row nine now
I don't I know instead of Yahweh you
will find it I don't I I don't I I don't
know if you read the book of Deuteronomy
chapter six verse number for Moses my
peace be upon him he says Shema Israel
Oh at the NOI elahi no at knowing even
hear o Israel your Lord the God is only
one God see now this word Yahweh this
term Yahweh according to the Ehlo hissed
and the youngest when he is figurative
it becomes a contradiction to the
concept of God mentioned in the Old
Testament if you read the book of exodus
chap number 20 verse number three four
and five and the book of Deuteronomy
chapter five verse number seven eight
and nine verbatim same to same word by
what they are the same what does it say
the god is saying you shall not make
unto yourself you shall not worship any
other God besides me you shall not make
unto yourself any graven image of
anything in the heavens above or
anything on the earth beneath or
anything in the waters beneath the earth
you shall not bow down yourself unto
them nor serve them for your Lord the
God am a jealous God if you observe this
teaching then if you say that Yahweh
spoke face to face llame he was a person
walk in the Eden it doesn't fit that
it's against the very tenets of your
teaching contradiction here it's
contentious file name and then they are
showing goddess absolutely so it's a
contradiction so it's very confusing to
understand the concept of God or Yahweh
in the Old Testament of the Bible or as
understood by the Jews they can't
explain of fixed definition for ED now
coming to Jesus Christ me peace be upon
him just one quick note so Yahweh it
started with the yhw H that was a
formation ok that's in the Hebrew yeah
it's in the Hebrew so now it got all the
way to the
english way Yahweh it became a delight
in a Greek okay all right so we clear
that up now Jesus Jesus Christ with
peace be upon him we all know no Muslim
is a Muslim unless he believes in Jesus
Christ will peace be upon him he has
been highly revered in the glorious
quran v muslims we believe because of
the Quran we Muslims have been made to
believe the Muslims of the time of
prophet muhammad aslam till the last
muslim on the face of the earth has been
made to believe that Jesus is an article
of faith in islam we do not
differentiate between any messengers of
God Allah said that the Muslims the
moment the true believers or those who
do not differentiate between the
messages of God we highly love respect
and revere Jesus Christ map will be also
so when I take my cries no Muslim is a
Muslim if he is Antichrist alright
that's clear no no Muslim is a Muslim if
he does not believe love and respect
Jesus Christ my peace be upon him no
Muslim is a Muslim if he does not
believe that Jesus Christ was a mighty
messenger of the Almighty God we Muslims
we believe that he was a mighty
messenger of god who healed those who
were born blind at lepers we believe he
gave life to the dead but all visited by
a las permission so we Muslims believe
in him the question is is Jesus Christ
Allah so I'm asking did Jesus say I am
Allah you read any Bible of the world
there is not a single unequivocal
statement I reiterate there is not a
single direct speech direct statement of
Jesus Christ may peace be upon him where
he ever said I am God or very sad
worship Me the for running Christian
evangelist they give an example they say
you see the president of America he does
not need to tell everybody every time
that I am the president of America they
forget to realize that the president of
America to become the president is
dependent upon the democracy so the
people already they have chosen in the
president so they know he is the
president of America but the God is not
chosen by the people he is the God by
himself so the God needs to educate the
people to show them that I am your God
who created you so it is an illogical
example it's an illogical parable to
give its
logical analogy so Jesus Christ never
said that i am the god or worship me so
they say he is one of the Trinity
surprisingly the word Trinity does not
occur in the Bible for one single time
it's not there no the word Trinity
doesn't convey so they say where is the
word tawheed in the hora well that topic
I will come again but the word Trinity
does not come in the Bible the closest
worse to tell treat reality in the Bible
was in king james version of the 16 and
11 christian era in the first episode of
John chapter number 5 verse number 7 8
and 9 which said and in the kingdom of
heaven bear three names the Father the
Son and the Holy Ghost and these three
are one this was the closest words you
read the Revised Standard Version of the
Bible that verse has been thrown into
the footnote as a manipulation
corruption concoction and something
added by the men into the Word of God
this one is no more day this was the
Christian scholars said right yeah 52
eminent scholars back by 32
denominations the three without saying
this verse is a corruption in the Bible
so the closest was to Trinity even that
is out of the Bible now and we're not
doing this odd i hate we're doing this
out of the love we want to educate and
we want the best for all of mankind but
you know what we got to get to the
bottom of this that's why we're digging
and we are unfolding the truth amazing
amazing facts not fiction here in the d
show will be right back for more when
the outside everything looks good you
see the hundred-thousand-dollar cars you
see a lot of diamonds you see a lot of
females and they think that this is you
know this is a life this is this is like
no paradise right here
with just anyone job to go into
someone's hard to change the hunt your
job is to topi what the truth is and the
alley over there is why we're sitting
here while i'm sitting here constantly
paying for the disease the kill was free
if allies by my side i am not afraid to
stand alone i am not afraid to stand
alone if allies by my side i am not
afraid to stand alone i am not afraid to
stand alone if Eliza I am not afraid to
stay
back here on the Dean show we're trying
to get out of the chaos and confusion
into the light into the straight path
the path that leads to paradise we want
to know what to call God the creator of
all that exists do we just call them god
no well let's go back to before you went
to break you have wrapping up this point
about the Trinity yeah so the SEC
Trinity is out of the Bible all the
clues was out of the Bible and one
statement see time does not permit me to
give I would have given references from
the Bible in line to prove that Jesus is
not the god but one reference in the
words of Jesus is enough to disprove
that is the God Jesus says in Gospel of
John chapter number 5 verse number 30 i
kin of mine own cell do nothing as I
hear I judge this is statement i kin of
mine on shall do nothing is enough to
prove that is not the God because God
does everything by himself give give
some references now just give a few that
also will support him not being God the
people who go check out going wholesome
Gospel of John chapter 5 verse number 30
and 31 Gospel of John chapter 5 verse
number 37 Gospel of John chapter 10
verse number 29 Gospel of John chapter
number 14 verse number 28 Gospel of John
cut number 17 verse number three and
four Gospel of Matthew chapter 20 verse
number 17 and 18 all these places Jesus
is denying himself to be the Almighty
God coming to the concept of God Allah
Allah is from the root arabic word Allah
and Allah means the God Allah is a name
that Allah preferred to use more often
than other names if you read the
glorious quran allah says in surah taha
surah number 20 at number 8 there is no
god except him except allah to him
belong the most beautiful names meaning
only one name is not there for the god
there are many beautiful names then
allah says in surah Annisa elsa number
79 behind 10 julio aha avi doraemon IM
matta KU follow los malos na call upon
him as allah or call upon him the most
gracious are I'm on to him belong the
most beautiful names what do you mean by
the most beautiful names most beautiful
names means the names in their meaning
and definition should be unique not
befitting anyone else not giving a
mental picture to you that is most
beautiful names and Allah says in surah
Araf surah number seven number 180 do
not
I to distort the name of Almighty God
Allah Subhan o Allah the concept of
understanding the names and attributes
of the Almighty God in Islam is referred
as tawheed which is derived from the
root word mojada and a hug used in the
Quran for Allah Subhan o Allah Allah is
warhead Eliza as referred in the
glorious quran in surah class 10 behind
12 at number one where Allah says Allah
and say to them is a lot the only one so
when you see though he's basically
categorized based on the teachings of
Quran and the teachings authentic
teachings of Mormonism into three main
categories to hit the rubia knowing the
rubia means to believe and to proclaim
to the mankind that Almighty God Allah
alone is the originator of the creation
and he alone cherishes and sustains them
all as referred in the Quran in surah
fatiha surah number one at number one
then throw he's a las ma was he fought
the beautiful names and attributes of
Allah they belong only to him his names
and attributes should not be given to
his creation neither sheltered the
attributes and names of creation be
given to Allah then Allah Subhan o Allah
is very clearly saying that if anyone
wants to use his name to christen
yourself to name yourself then prefix up
or a month up in Arabic means servant
for email it is up for a female it is a
month then the last category of coheed
is Tauheed ebody meaning all the methods
that you use according to the teachings
of Muhammad sallallahu so long to
worship Almighty God Allah Subhan o
Allah should not be raped repeated to
revere respect or worship anyone except
a las 10 dolla the best definition of
Almighty God in theology in the study
about God universally can be given from
the Quran in surah ikhlas 40 number 9 12
verse number at number 12 I over 4 which
is the touchstone of theology where
Allah says bismillahi rahmani rain
colville la odd say to them he is Allah
the only one Allah whose summit he is
absolute and eternal he is independent
he does not depend upon anyone but
everyone besides same depend only upon
him Samuel is volim you lot he has no
parents and he gives birth to no
children well I me a cool know who cufon
earth and there is no one like unto him
this is the best for line definition of
the Almighty God any sample of
whether it is Jesus Yahweh any sample of
God if they can fit this for line
definition V Muslims have no objection
to take that as a las 10 donna but
wallah by God except Allah nobody can
pass that test it's very simple now so
very simple very sad wonder Stan if you
have an open heart open my you want to
know the truth this makes sense yeah and
it's the best definition it gives the
royalty to the Almighty God it gives the
glory to the Almighty God in that
definition and we never bring down gas
his Croatia making him walk on earth
giving him a color giving him now all
these we don't make much gay leather
stitching clothes sailor stitching
clothes nothing god is god the crater is
the crater allows a lot and we are his
creation yes Daddy Cool that's as simple
as that Islam is saying only worship
that one guy yes 100 plus a 2 year old
con estas a lot thank you very much for
be Legolas and I got Almighty the cradle
of the Lord Salaam alaikum alaikum
assalaam dhaka and that's all the time
that we have and i'm going to agree with
a lot of people out there that we
shouldn't have to follow it organized
religion organized by man or men but we
should follow the way of life that's
been organized ordained sent down to
vonlee from the divine from the create
tour from the one god the creator of all
that is is because he knows best he
knows best but he's the most wisest he's
the most loving he's the most merciful
and that's why he sent messengers to
guide us and the way of life that he
wants us to live is always been the same
same submit your entire self not to
yourself not to Jesus not to the Sun not
to the moon now to anything in creation
but to the create tour the one God and
do good base your life on doing all the
good things that he told you to do and
at the end what do you got what he got
then you got his pleasure and his
paradise and then you avoid his Hellfire
and that's a hot place where we don't
want to be but it starts with you
wanting it it starts with you wanting it
so wanted as for it call upon that one
God call upon him alone and Arabic is
Allah the most loving the most merciful
and then only then will the guidance
start to come and continue to come back
here to the D show every week you can
also contact us here at 1 866 to Islam
until next time p
be with you